[Music]
on this Tuesday night the political
fight delaying emergency aid to
Canadians
the Liberals plan to pass an emergency
bill during this pandemic hits a
roadblock
hell no plus the message the Prime
Minister cannot stress enough stay home
president Trump's prediction for when
the US economy will be back in business
I'd love to have it open by Eastern
critics say it could cost millions of
lives
deepening dangers in the line of duty
the risks are paramedics faced and stuck
in a precarious position in Peru every
day goes by and we have no information
Canadians
desperate to get home
global national with Donna freezin
good evening and thanks for joining us
the middle of a pandemic seems like the
worst time for politicians to bicker
over how to help Canadians but it's
happening the federal government has
promised to deliver eighty two billion
dollars in emergency aid but now that is
stalled an emergency session of
Parliament has been suspended I'll tell
you why in just a moment first where
we're at with this virus more and more
Canadians are getting sick and this
message needs to be repeated this is
serious the decisions you make have
serious consequences not just on your
community but on the entire country if
you want to things things to get back to
normal do your part stay home here's why
staying home is crucial Canada's Public
Health Agency says 90% of new cases in
the last week are linked to community
spread that means people are getting it
from someone else in the community and
it's a dramatic shift from a few weeks
ago in most reported cases in Canada
where the result of overseas travel
really our primary strategy is to ensure
people are self isolating when they
should be and also that everyone is
respecting social distancing if we're
going to get a handle on community
spread everybody has to respect those
measures more than 700 new cases were
reported across Canada today Quebec had
the biggest daily spike 395 new cases
today Ontario there are now a total of
588 cases including 31 health care
workers in total across Canada more than
2,700 people have now tested positive
for Kovan 19 a small group of MPs went
to Ottawa today for an emergency sitting
of Parliament we'd been told they'd all
agreed to pass a bill to help Canadians
who have lost their jobs or can't buy
groceries or pay the bills or have to
stay home because they're sick but it
derailed and Parliament has been
suspended while MPs negotiate a way
through the impasse Mike look at or on
politics during a pandemic
extraordinary measures for an
extraordinary session of Parliament the
speaker's parade reflecting the physical
distancing being asked of all Canadians
but what was being asked of this
Parliament too much according to some
opposition MPs like Scott Reid the
conservative defied his own party's
orders to stay away from the House of
Commons because he wanted more scrutiny
on the government's 82 billion dollar
emergency stimulus bill an early draft
would have given sweeping taxation
powers to Finance Minister Bill Morneau
until the end of the year 2021 you can
imagine how shocked we all were a
conservative finance critic Pierre Poli
EV is in self-isolation but shared his
feelings widely on Twitter we said hell
no we will not grant unanimous consent
for such a bill to even come before the
House of Commons the government took
that provision out of the bill but left
in powers for other ministers to spend
money to help fight the pandemic and
while the Prime Minister says he
respects Parliament's role to oversee
spending he says this situation is
unique we recognize that this pandemic
is moving extremely quickly and it is an
exceptional situation that requires
extreme flexibility and rapidity of
response by governments to be able to
help Canadians that flexibility the
government says would allow it to craft
more economic measures to deal with more
layoffs like tuesday's announcements
from Bombardier of more than 1,200
temporary layoffs and WestJet's loss of
nearly 7,000 employees we are here today
to pass the measures that were announced
to help people get through the next few
days and weeks and time is of the
essence not only to help those people
but because this legislation still has
to get through the Senate which is
scheduled to deal with this bill in its
own special sitting Wednesday morning
Donna all right Mike ligature in Ottawa
Thanks here's a staggering figure almost
1 million Canadians applied for
employment insurance just in the past
week that is a record for this country
and it gives you some sense of the
urgency for so many Canadians
and businesses who need financial help
Mercedes Stevenson is with me from
Ottawa Mercedes this is the kind of
thing that drives people crazy about
politicians but I guess late tonight
there's word there may be some progress
there may be some hope on the horizon
for that eighty two billion dollar aid
bill to start moving I'm being told by
sources on both sides of the aisle that
there is a new draft bill now I'm
hearing the opposition has not yet
received it but they have been told by
the Liberal government that it is coming
and I'm hearing that it is expected to
address some of those sticking points
that the NDP and the Conservatives had
about the sweeping powers that the
liberals wanted federally for cabinet
ministers to have to be able to tax and
spend without parliamentary Authority or
approval earlier tonight we spoke with
conservative leader Andrew Shearer about
what the holdup is and why he didn't
want to vote for the original Liberal
bill here's what he told us the
government is choosing to link the
financial measures that we support to a
whole other series of proposals changing
the way Parliament operates there's no
need for that we could vote right away
on the financial package to get that out
the door that would then allow space and
time for parliamentarians to negotiate
how we are going to do our job in the
weeks ahead the NDP and the Liberals
apart me the NDP and the Conservatives
wanted to just deal with the economic
aid package that may be happening now
with this new draft bill we'll have to
wait and see Donna
but perhaps the money will start flowing
sooner rather than later
all right Mercedes Stevenson in Ottawa
thank you one bright spot today the
prospect of trillions of dollars in
government stimulus around the world
boosted the stock market the TSX surged
more than eight percent today up at
thousand points at times after hitting
its lowest level since October 2011
yesterday the Dow Jones jumped nine
percent today about 1800 points but
there's such volatility right now it's
impossible to know what will happen
tomorrow well we know there are lots of
people who work who can't work from home
and whose jobs potentially put them in
direct contact with the virus paramedics
for example as my
Armstrong explains this pandemic makes
their job more complex and dangerous
than ever before one of the worst
outbreaks of kovat 19 in the country is
this retirement home east of Montreal
there have been four deaths in this one
location it may also be one of the
reasons the local ambulance service is
down 17 paramedics back tsukino know
they can heave cough director of
operations says two of his paramedics
have tested positive five have symptoms
that are waiting for tests and Tanner
and self isolation as a precaution
between all the extra cleaning and the
overtime the service has been stretched
to its limits by X well now and you
talked about the director says right now
they can make do but it's hard and they
can't keep losing people kovat 19 is
complicating work for ambulance services
right across the country two paramedics
in Toronto have tested positive and
another in Waterloo Ontario it's not an
easy job in normal times right now it's
even tougher there's a six foot or 2
meter safety this trial paramedics now
start every call with an evaluation they
ask the patient whether they've traveled
recently that determines whether they
have to wear the full protective gear
but one of the problems paramedics are
finding is people aren't always telling
the truth if you are sick or you think
you're sick please tell us that's that's
number one we don not see Quebec Health
Minister appealed for honesty Monday
it's a matter of life or death he said
and this isn't the time for lying on one
of the calls to the retirement home
paramedics were in contact with a person
who said they hadn't traveled they later
admitted they had but said they didn't
have any symptoms they did my carbs for
Global News joliet Quebec community
spread is what public health experts
fear the most and it's happening in
Canada now the virus is spreading from
person to person in our communities the
thing is it can't infect people it can't
reach and that's why keeping physically
distant from people matters so much
right now
Eric Sorenson explains even when we
gather we're keeping apart the
behavioral shift in society has been
astounding with exceptions an entire
population has begun to maintain
distance the urgency made clear by the
spike
almost 800 kovat 19 cases reported in
Quebec the last two days I know we're
going through difficult times I know
it's stressful the premier telling
Quebecers it will be temporary but only
if Canadians carry through with physical
distancing ninety percent of cases are
now linked to community transmission not
international travel and it's harder to
track community transmission
we've now shut down conferences and mass
gatherings and you know people are
reducing any gatherings of over 50 but
in fact going even more stringent than
that we're saying stay home and maintain
a two meter distance from others it'll
require a long period of
community-minded separation here's the
trend in Canada one month ago there were
11 confirmed cases we passed 100
confirmed cases on March 11th we
surpassed 500 on the 17th 1020 a--the
and 2,000 on the 23rd it suggests new
cases are now more than doubling every
four days and at that rate we could see
10,000 cases or more by the end of March
which is just next Tuesday the doubling
time initially will be three days or
four days and then it starts to get
shorter and shorter as the more and more
cases happen and that's what we were
seeing in Italy and our hope is that we
can kind of keep that rate as low as we
can the risk is to all of us of getting
the disease and overwhelming our
hospitals in this critical period but if
we're not aggressively implementing
social distancing measures then that is
not that's going to be a problem that is
going to be a problem for every hospital
every hospital in the country
Francois Lugo is blunt about the job in
front of us all the faster we'll limit
contagion the faster we'll save lives
Eric Sorenson Global News Toronto the
2020 Olympic Games in Tokyo have been
postponed it's the first time the
Olympics have been rescheduled because
of a pandemic on a phone call with the
International Olympic Committee
president japan's Prime Minister agreed
to delay the games Shinzo Abe a says
they will happen no later than next
summer
and finally Jr's Shah the founder of
Shaw Communications has died he was a
pioneer of Canadian business a visionary
of the telecommunications
the Order of Canada recipient bill Shaw
communications and Corus Entertainment
which owns Global News into one of
Canada's top companies he was also known
for his support for many philanthropic
causes jerry Shaw was 85 years old we've
been inundated with your questions about
kovat 19 can the virus live on fruits
and vegetables for example we'll ask the
experts coming up
there's a new warning from the World
Health Organization they say The Cove in
19 virus is now spreading so quickly
that social distancing must absolutely
continue but it won't be enough to
completely slow it down
they say countries must be much more
aggressive with testing testing every
suspected case and quarantine close
contacts in order to flatten the curve
here's how this pandemic has accelerated
it took 67 days from the first reported
case to reach 100,000 cases another 11
days to reach 200,000 and just four days
to reach 300,000 now 84 days since the
first case there are close to 400,000
cases it's now clear the US could soon
be the next epicenter of this global
crisis the spread of the virus is
accelerating their frightening ly fast
there were more than nine thousand new
cases confirmed just today that's the
biggest increase of any country yet
President Donald Trump says he wants to
get everyone back to work by April 12th
at least one top public health official
says that could lead to millions of
deaths Jackson prosecco reports from the
sprawling Convention Center that will
soon become a one thousand bed hospital
New York's governor issued a dire
warning the rate of cases the rate of
new infections is doubling about every
three days medical equipment is already
in short supply a quarter of those
hospitalized are in intensive care
now there are predictions of a tidal
wave of cases over the next three weeks
that will overwhelm the system we're not
slowing it and it is accelerating on its
own but in Washington President Donald
Trump urged a speedy return to normal
life but you're gonna lose more people
by putting a country into a massive
recession or depression Digital is
people just halfway through his own
two-week campaign to slow the spread
Trump now suggests social distancing and
business closures aren't worth the
economic toll I'd love to have it open
by Easter I think at this time this is a
little bit too early experts have warned
lifting restrictions too soon would
be disastrous if you let it run rampant
at least parts of the health system
could get overwhelmed that's already the
reality in New York and we're not going
to put a dollar figure on human life
where the state has just a fraction of
the 30,000 ventilators and 140,000
hospital beds it needs and where
officials are now begging the federal
government to order production to meet
expected demand Jackson frost Co Global
News Washington
India has taken extreme measures to
avert catastrophe the entire country 1.3
billion people have been ordered to stay
home for 21 days Prime Minister Narendra
Modi says as of midnight everyone should
forget what going out means though he
says essential things like food and
medicine will be available there are
only about 500 confirmed cases in the
India but testing has been limited and a
spike is expected and this is Britain
under lockdown everyone in the country
under strict orders to stay home except
to get food and do limited exercise
gatherings of more than 2 people are
banned and only essential workers are
allowed out the lockdown is set to be in
place for three weeks that's up for
review though Britain recorded its
highest single death toll today 87 new
deaths still ahead the Canadians in Peru
waiting to come home
in the past week alone 1 million
Canadians have returned to Canada from
abroad and the Prime Minister has a
strong message for them if you've just
returned from abroad go straight home
from the airport and do not leave for at
least 14 days this is not a suggestion
work is underway to repatriate other
Canadians who are still stuck abroad and
as Ross Lord reports in this time of
crisis rescuing everyone right away is
proving to be impossible
among the throngs of tourists in Peru
desperate to return home there are
thousands of Canadians like this group
of high school students from Vancouver
college they came to help build a home
for a single mother then the Cova 19
outbreak escalated forcing the
government of Peru to close its borders
and force everyone into quarantine there
is a lot of underlying stress especially
when they phone home you can see that
they're just trying to hold it together
Lilian vernier is managing her own
stress a medical problem that requires
an intravenous procedure every two
months to keep the condition at bay
after 2 weeks that I've missed my
injection that could but that my
condition will will become more
problematic and that 2 weeks comes up on
Friday Friday is when the last of three
scheduled Air Canada flights from Peru
to Canada is due to leave passengers
receive a code in advance so as soon as
we get a code we need to book our ticket
pay for our ticket and then hopefully we
we make it before everybody else it's
becoming a competition we're checking
our emails every five minutes Diego
Martinez his wife Gabriella and their
daughter Margot are torn they urgently
want to return to Toronto rather than
risk being infected and at the mercy of
Peru's overwhelmed health care system
but they're distraught about leaving
their hosts Gabriella's parents I don't
think my my dad who's suffering of
Alzheimer's would make it and if he gets
infected
if he gets infected I got four big but
that's a scary thought if I have
I mean if I'm called into one of those
remaining two flights the Canadian
embassy says it's working to secure more
flights as the emotional effects of the
crisis deepened Ross Lord what will use
a frosty reminder on keeping your
physical distance next we know the
situation in Canada and around the world
is getting more serious by the day and
then it could be hard to keep track of
all the advice and the directions that
are being given from various public
health officials we know you have lots
of questions too so we have put our
Jeff's simple on the hunt for some
answers Jeff well Donna last week about
a million Canadians returned to the
country from abroad after being urged by
the federal government to get back here
ASAP they along with many others are now
being ordered to remain in
self-isolation
and many viewers are now writing to ask
what self-isolation actually means the
confusion around self isolating indoors
might be due in part to some mixed
messages from health officials please
stay home stay home the advice we give
to every international traveler
returning which is you know still stay
at home while others including Canada's
chief medical officer are opening the
door and if you do need to venture out
feel fresher keep your hands away from
your face and practice meticulous hand
washing one viewer wrote I'm hoping
somebody can be a bit more clear on the
self isolation guidelines people are
supposed to stay at home it doesn't mean
go out to get groceries
it doesn't mean go to the park it
doesn't mean go for a jog it means stay
at home and he says everyone should keep
their distance but what does a safe
distance actually look like well the
World Health Organization is asking
people to stand at least one meter apart
while public health officials here in
Canada are going even further asking
people to stand at least two meters or
six and a half feet
from each other depending on the
strength of the sneeze and the amount of
stuff that you sneeze it could be 3 3
feet a meter Canadians are trying to
keep their distance but one place many
still need to go is their local grocery
store and that's prompted a lot of
viewers to write in to ask this somebody
had coughed on the food there's an off
chance there could be something there
this is part of the reason why we
suggest you know to wash your hand
before you eat and you're gonna be
washing your products anyway that should
eliminate that risk another viewer asked
how long the crisis is likely to last or
before a vaccine can be mobilized he
locked down these the the physical
distancing measures I think they're
gonna be going on for at least four if
not six weeks but even the most
optimistic official estimates suggests
that a vaccine is at least a year down
the road underscoring an uncomfortable
message we've got a long way to go Donna
a long way to stay away from each other
Jeff simple in Toronto thanks that is
global national for this Tuesday I'm
donor freezing just one more reminder to
stay home and practice social distancing
and where there's still some snow on the
ground these snowmen are helping to
spread the message too thanks for
watching and take care of yourself
[Music]
you